اكثر من مليون شجره زرعت في منطقه جازان
خلال الاشهر الماضيه ضمن مبادره السعوديه
الخضراء بما تم استحداثه واجهه بحريه
بمساحه 350,000 متر مربع
ستربط الكورنيش بضحيه الملك عبد الله التي
تحوي اربعين الف قطعه سكنيه فضلا عن
معالجه التشوهات البصريه في المدينه
ينضم الينا مراسل العربيه اسامه القاسم
اسامه مرحبا بك اسامه يعني ضعنا في تفاصيل
هذه المشروعات في منطقه جازان
اهلا وسهلا خالي تحيه طيبه لك ولجميع
مشاهدي قناه العربيه نتحدث اليوم بالتاكيد
من هنا من منطقه جازان وبالتحديد من امام
مواجهتها البحريه عدد المشاريع التي نفذت
اليوم في امانه جازان وايضا المشاريع
المستقبليه كبيره جدا تفوق العشرين مشروعا
منها انسنت الطرق وايضا تحسين المشهد
الحضري نتحدث اليوم ايضا خالد عن عدد كبير
جدا من البرامج التي قامت بها الامانه وفي
خبر حصري للعربيه امانه جازان تستهدف
انشاء ممشى يعتبر اطول المماسي الذي
يتجاوز طوله 25 كم مربع والذي يربط
الواجهات البحريه في بعضها البعض وجهها
جازان البحريه اليوم سبع واجهات كاكثر
منطقه في السعوديه اترككم الان في جوله
ايضا حول المشاريع التي تم تنفيذها هنا في
امانه منطقه جازان ايضا امام جازان تستهدف
خلال شتاء جازان زراعه اكثر من 300,000
زهره ضمن برنامج شتاء تحدث اليوم ايضا
خالد عن هذه المشاريع النوعيه كون ان
منطقه جازان ايضا اصبحت منطقه جادي
باستثمارين خصوصا بعد الاتفاقيات الصينيه
السعوديه كل هذه البرامج واكثر تعطي ايحاء
جديده ووجهه جديده بان جازان اصبحت منطقه
واعده بكل تاكيد هذه المشاريع واكثر التي
نفذتها امانه منطقه جازان من خلال ايضا
تكثيف الغطاء النباتي الحديث اكثر عن هذه
المشاريع يسعدني ان يكون معي الان الامين
امين منطقه جازان المهندس يحيى غزواني
للحديث اكثر عن هذه المشاريع اهلا وسهلا
فيك مهندس ابتداءا معنا اليوم في النشاط
الرابع حدثني اليوم عن ما هي المشاريع
التي قمتم بها في امانه جازان في تحسين
المشهد الحضري
مساء الخير يا اسامه لك ولي زملائك في
الاستديو سعيد بتواجد معكم في قناه
العربيه وميسي على مشاهديكم خلف الشاشات
ااا في البدايه تقدم
بجزيره الشكر والتقدير لصاحب السوري
الملكي امير المنطقه وسمو نائبه ولمعالي
وزير الشؤون البلديه والكرويه على ما نجده
في امانه منطقه جازان من دعم همم كبير جدا
وشكر موصول لزملائي رائعين في الامانه
والبلديات المرتبطه همم يعتبر تحسين
المشهد الحضري احد اهم البرامج التي تعمل
عليها الامانه لرفع مستوى اا جوده الحياه
في منطقه جاذبه سياحيه واقتصاديا كما
منطقه جازان خلال فتره الماضيه ركزنا على
معالجه شوهه البصريه ولازلنا نعمل همم
عليها ضمن خطه وطنيه موحده همم استحدثنا
شاطئ جديد همم شمال موقعنا الحالي بمساحه
تقارب
350,000 متر اوبا يعتبر امتداد الواجهه
البحريه همم
الشماليه عملنا على زياده نصيب همم الفرد
من الساحات والمسطحات الخضراء وتتجاوزنا
مستهدفات العام 20 22 بنسبه 135% اذا
مهندس تعني اسالك ايضا سؤال اخر منطقه
جازان جبليه ساحليه بحريه بالتاكد انه هذا
يعطي تنوع كبير جدا على المستوى السياحي
ما هي الرؤيه المستقبليه اليوم لامانه
جازان في هذا التنوع نعمل حقيقه في همم
الفتره القادمه على مشاريع النوعيه اهمها
ربط الكورنيش الشمالي بضاحيه الملك عبد
الله طبعا الضاحيه هي مخطط نموذج نادر على
مستوى المملكه 40,000 قطعه سكنيه
وشاطئ بطون 16 كيلو همم يرتبط بمطار الملك
عبد الله ايضا نعمل على همم التوسع في
الملاعب والماشي وحاليا نعمل على ممشى
الواجهه الذي شرط بالهي في مقدمتكم وهو
يعتبر من اطول المماشي نعمل ايضا على
تطوير وانسنت العشوائيات ولتو رجعنا من
جوله مع سمو امير المنطقه للعشوائيات جنوب
همم همم المدينه وخلال الفتره القادمه ان
شاء الله سنعمل على عشوائيات همم
العشوايات في العشيمه همم نستلف في الفتره
همم القادمه مشاركه القطاع الخاص همم في
تطوير همم البنيه التحتيه وانشاء مشاريع
ترفيهيه نوعيه وهمم واسامه استغل همم من
دربكم هنا لدعوه كبار رجال الاعمال
والمستثمرين على التوجه الى منطقه جازان
وسنقوم بتقديم كل ما يلزم من همم دعمه
وتسهيل الامور ان شاء الله
المهندس يحي غزواني وانت امين منطقه جازان
شكرا لك اذا اتحدث اليوم ايضا خالد عن
شتاء جازان وهو عرس جيزان الست السنوي
الذي سوف يحكم بحول الله تعالى في مطرح
هذا الشهر تحديدا في الثاني عشر من يناير
يعني يقول ايضا خاتمه خالد وانا في هذه
المنطقه في اجواء جازان الساحره ان رحله
البحث عن السعاده والترفيه والجمال تنتهي
هناك
تقريبا من 23 الى 28 في هذا التوتل
المهرجان وان شاء الله